bah pour obtenir des hommes je suis
connue je suis Florence Foresti tu
m'embrasses non pas vrai
et ça fait très longtemps que j'ai plus
de rituel j'ai 48 ans donc le matin déjà
c'est constaté que je suis en vie et
savoir où j'ai mal
[Musique]
moi je suis très casanière donc jamais
de chez moi avec mes proches ça peut
être tout ce qui me console et le soleil
bien sûr parce qu'on vieillissant il y a
plus que le soleil qui nous importe je
vais finir comme une vieille retraitée
niçoise ça c'est certain je serai au
bord de l'eau
[Musique]
je l'attends avec impatience
la fumée la cigarette la nicotine la
vaporette maintenant la vapoteuse
ah je cuisine pas je suis nulle si
vraiment je dois recevoir des amis et
que des livres ou est fermé c'est des
lasagnes
hérité de mon grand-père
[Musique]
boire et fumer
tu fumes beaucoup boire et fumer toute
seule c'est mon grand grand luxe
qu'est-ce que je voulais faire et ton
enfant certainement le métier que je
fais aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'ai fait une école de cinéma j'aurais
bon j'étais nul hein mais si j'étais pas
humoriste bah je serais restée graphiste
j'étais graphiste j'étais pas mal
maintenant si tu me demandais maintenant
je serai le vœu de bouledogue ça c'est
sûr ou bien
je me demande si
institutrice j'aurais pas aimé je crois
que j'aurais aimé
j'en ai plein j'en ai trop j'ai une
carrière qui offre tellement de supers
souvenirs j'en ai pas un comme ça en
mémoire à chaque fois c'est les
premières de spectacle c'est vraiment ce
que je préfère au monde c'est les
premières c'est une émotion incroyable
la première fois qu'on sort un spectacle
d'une heure une heure et quart devant un
public un spectacle tout neuf qui a
jamais été testé c'est magique
il arrive des choses chiantes sur scène
il y a des soirs où tu es pas bon alors
qu'il y a la personne que tu aimes dans
la salle il y a des soirs où tu prends
des pas des bides mais où tu es ouais ou
tu es pas à la hauteur un spectacle
vivant c'est toujours l'occasion d'être
de se dépasser de passer un bon moment
et des fois tu passes des mauvais
moments et ça c'est très triste
[Musique]
alors franchement il y a un truc pas mal
où j'ai pas honte de m'en servir c'est
parfois à l'hôpital quand j'ai des amis
candés quand la famille malade je dis
attends je viens avec toi comme ça
peut-être il le traiteront un peu mieux
c'est horrible parce que normalement
c'est le lieu de toutes les égalités
mais parfois ça aide à avoir un petit
rendez-vous médical plus vite c'est
horrible si ça peut servir à ça c'est
pas mal et puis aussi je me sers de ma
notoriété pour des associations qui ont
besoin de lumière
[Musique]